DONNA SCHUT: Hi, everyone.
Hope you're safe and doing well.
Thank you for joining this
session on Google Cloud's AI
Adoption Framework.
AI is increasingly
the new frontier
in digital transformation
and is well positioned
to drive value across all
aspects of an organization.
We believe that the
enterprises that
invest in building custom
AI and industry solutions
are better positioned to be
the global economic leaders
of tomorrow.
As McKinsey's paper
"Modeling the Impact of AI
on the World Economy" indicated,
companies that fully absorb AI
could double their cash flow.
We will be presenting
on a framework aimed
at enabling organizations
to build an effective AI
capability informed by
Google's own evolution in AI
as well as many
years of experience
in helping cloud customers
solve complex challenges
from startups to enterprises
in various industries.
So if you're looking to help
your organization leverage
AI successfully, whether
at the start or far
along your journey, you
are in the right session.
As you may have
seen, we recently
published a white
paper on this which
Khalid and I wrote with
the help of many experts
from across Google.
Our coauthors Barbara,
Finn, Valentine, Lak,
and us are available to
answer your questions
during this week.
To briefly introduce
ourselves, I'm
Donna, the technical
account manager
defining strategic roadmaps with
our advanced machine-learning
customers and
overseeing the delivery
of large-scale,
cutting-edge projects.
KHALID SALAMA: And I'm Khalid,
a cloud solutions architect
focusing on designing
and building
machine-learning
systems in Google Cloud.
DONNA SCHUT: Before going
into the framework itself,
I wanted to share why I'm
so passionate about this.
I used to play chess at
an international level,
and this sparked
my interest in AI.
It showed me how AI can push
the boundaries of our thinking
and accelerate our learning.
A good example of
this is AlphaZero,
a machine-learning
system developed
by DeepMind that plays chess.
This gave a new
perspective on how
to effectively play the game.
And in a similar
way, AI can give us
a new perspective on how to
solve business challenges.
More than ever, I
think it's important
that we leverage AI to tackle
the big societal problems
like health and sustainability.
While the value of AI is clear,
building an AI capability
presents challenges.
Customers often seek
our advice on how
they can leverage machine
learning effectively
to gain business value.
They ask us questions like,
what role should we hire?
and how should we
structure our teams?
As you move from creating
models to putting them
into production, different
skill sets are required.
And how can we make data
discoverable, shareable,
and reusable?
One of the key
blockers of AI adoption
is the lack of high-quality
data and making
it accessible in a secure way.
On top of that, they ask us,
how can we deploy and operate
machine-learning models
in production at scale?
Customers aspire to run powerful
algorithms on large data sets
while controlling cost.
Building an AI
capability encompasses
many different aspects, and
focusing on just one aspect,
like the technology and not the
people needed to implement it,
can result in wasted
resources and no impact.
That's why it's so important
to have a clear roadmap.
Working with
customers, we wanted
to help them be
successful no matter where
they are in their journey,
so a year ago we envisioned
a framework to
enable organizations
to leverage machine
learning effectively
and gain business value.
Chess is about creating a
vision and defining the steps
to get there.
We applied the same structure
to building AI capabilities
and conceived the AI
Adoption Framework.
Google Cloud's AI
Adoption Framework
is essentially a guide
for organizations
who want to build an
effective AI capability.
The framework covers
the questions customers
have asked us in the
areas of the technology
to develop platforms and
solutions, the people who
will implement and
manage that technology,
the data that fuels
that technology,
and the processes that
govern the whole of it.
Success requires an integrated
lens between these areas.
The interplay between
these four areas
gives rise to six themes--
learn, lead, access,
secure, scale, and automate.
Based on our experience
with customers,
these are the six
themes you need
to address to be successful.
To briefly introduce
each theme--
learn is the interplay
between people and technology.
It entails hiring talent,
upskilling your staff
through learning
programs, and working
with experienced partners.
Lead is the interplay
between people and process.
It refers to leaders
sponsoring AI initiatives
and how teams are structured
and collaborate with each other.
Access is the interplay
between people and data.
It's about data
management and making
data assets and machine-learning
artifacts discoverable,
shareable, and reusable.
Secure is the interplay
between data and process.
It addresses how you
classify and protect
data, build their systems,
and implement responsible AI
practices.
Scale is the interplay
between data and technology.
It covers how you use
cloud-native services to scale
with big data sets and
a large number of jobs
without operational overhead.
And lastly, automate
is the interplay
between technology and process.
It encompasses
deploying, executing,
and operating technology for
machine-learning pipelines
in production efficiently,
frequently, and reliably.
Your readiness is determined by
your current business practices
in each of the six themes
across three phases--
tactical, strategic,
and transformational.
In the tactical
phase, the focus is
on easy adoption, minimal
disruption, and quick wins.
Different teams experiment
with simple analytics
use cases and benefit from
improved actionable insights
from data--
for example, using
basic descriptive
analytics to create a
customer-segmentation model.
Complex problems are
outsourced to partners.
In the strategic
phase, AI is used
to deliver sustainable business
value for your organization.
You typically form
a centralized team,
ensuring coordination,
consistent standards,
and governance.
A broader vision
steers AI adoption,
and your organization has
several machine-learning
systems deployed and maintained
in production, like propensity
modeling, demand forecasting,
and recommendations,
leveraging data sets from an
enterprise data warehouse.
In the transformational
phase, AI
plays a key role in
the organization,
stimulating innovation
and supporting agility
to create state of
the art algorithms--
for example, using
the language model
BERT to extract information
and answer questions
from COVID research papers.
You cultivate a culture where
experimentation and learning
is continuous and encouraged.
Machine-learning
expertise has diffused
across the lines of
business, and there's
a mechanism in place for
scaling and promoting
machine-learning capabilities
across the organization.
All teams are empowered through
a platform that enables access
to useful data sets, prepared
features, reusable components,
and trained models.
When you overlay
the six themes--
learn, lead, access, secure,
scale, and automate--
and the three phases--
tactical, strategic,
and transformational--
you get the AI Maturity Scale.
You can use the AI Maturity
Scale to assess where you are
and define where you want to go.
The goal isn't necessarily
to become transformational
in every aspect but to get
value every step of the way.
Now I'll hand over to
Khalid who will dive deeper
into the Maturity
Scale for each theme.
KHALID SALAMA: Thank you, Donna.
So the first theme
to discuss is learn.
As Donna mentioned,
it concerns aspects
like upskilling, hiring, and
collaboration with partners.
In the tactical
phase, we've seen
that learning about data
science and machine learning
is usually isolated
and self-motivated.
Your organization tends to
turn to third-party consultants
when facing compelling
machine-learning use cases
rather than hiring to fill
the gaps in the skill set.
As your organization starts to
build a greater AI capability
in-house, you hire
the required skills
for data science and
machine learning.
Typically, organizations
start to hire
machine-learning engineers in
addition to data scientists
to be able to productionize
their machine-learning models.
You also develop clear learning
[INAUDIBLE] with certification
to upskill your stuff.
For example, using our
Google Cloud training
and certification programs.
We've recently launched the
Professional Machine Learning
Engineer Certification to
assess your team's ability
to design and build a
machine-learning system
in Google Cloud.
Platform a partnership
perspective,
your organization chooses
a strategic partner
to provide specialized knowledge
in specific AI use cases.
For example, automating
document processing
or building conversational apps.
Moving to the
transformational phase,
we've seen customers encouraging
P2P and community learning,
creating internal
knowledge bases and wikis,
and allowing staff rotations
across business functions
to ensure tighter collaboration
and exchange of experience.
Your organization
now aims at hiring
AI and machine-learning
talent with industry expertise
to lead research and
innovation efforts.
Now let's move to
the lead theme which
concerns with
business-leadership support
and team structure
and collaboration.
In the early phase
of the maturity,
AI adoption is driven by
individual contributors
with little or no
executive sponsorship.
Thus the machine
learning initiatives
might not have a clear alignment
with your organization's
strategic goals.
The key step is to start with
your organization business
strategy and
priority to identify
the right
machine-learning use cases
and pursue executive
sponsorship.
As your senior executives
realize the importance of AI
for creating
competitive advantage,
they support and
fund AI projects
to deliver value for
various business functions.
Now you can establish a
centralized cross-functional
advanced analytics team to
standardize the practices
and guidelines and to
achieve strategic AI agenda.
This advanced
analytics team works
on delivering prioritized
machine-learning projects
and proactively clarifying
how AI can effectively
address different use cases.
In the transformational
phase, each functional team
has its own data scientists
with the right domain-specific
expertise.
Having a centralized
machine-learning engineering
team and embedding that
scientists in the business
functions ensures both
strong technical standards
and effective business aligns.
As AI shows to be
impactful to your business,
the C-level executives
continuously
demonstrate active sponsor
for innovative AI products.
Such research and
innovation projects
aim at solving cutting-edge
business problems
and establishing the
organization name as a market
leader.
The third theme in
our framework is
access, which concerns
effective data management
to enable shareability,
discoverability,
and reuseablity.
In the early stages,
each team usually
manages its own data island
and machine-learning assets
with no sharing
among other teams.
As a tactical step to
update your strategy,
you can look into building
a data lake containing
their own structured
and unstructured data
feeds from across your
disparate systems.
This can form the foundation
for collecting, curating,
and sharing data across
your organization
and creating managed
information objects.
As your organization recognizes
data as a vital enterprise
asset that fuels AI, you invest
in building an enterprise data
warehouse which provides
an integrated information
store and a unified data
model for different business
functions.
The data warehouse empowers
data analysts, data scientists,
and data engineers
to perform their data
wrangling, exploration,
and analytics activities.
For example, we work
with a media customer
that successfully uses BigQuery
as their enterprisewide data
warehouse.
This enabled their various teams
to perform analytical queries
and information retrieval
from a centralized location.
Besides, you start
to put together
a centralized repository
for machine-learning assets
like notebooks
and code templates
and develop tools for
annotating and categorizing
deficits and other
assets to enable
discoverability and usability.
Data quality management
at this stage
is a business variety to
ensure the right foundation
for analytics and AI.
In the transformational
phase, your organization
is actively working to
develop the technology
and processes to allow data
scientists to create, share,
discover, and reuse data
and machine-learning
assets across different
teams and functions.
Moreover, standardizing the
definition, storage, and access
of machine learning
data sets, you
invest in implementing
a feature store.
A feature store can be
a federated [INAUDIBLE]
repository for
registering new features
and discovering existing ones
to be used by data scientists.
Now we move to the secure theme.
A secure theme concerns
with protecting your data,
securing your
machine-learning services,
and ensuring responsible AI.
As a tactical step to enable
AI adoption with confidence,
your organization defines the
identity and access-management
policies and security controls
to protect your data and AI
services.
In addition, you
ensure data privacy
through constant sensitive-data
classification and obfuscation.
In the strategic phase,
your organization
starts to implement a
comprehensive data-governance
program covering data-access
auditing, lineage tracking,
data privacy and compliance,
and establishing responsible AI
practices.
Responsible AI practices
ensure building
fair and explainable
AI solutions
to maintain the
desired level of trust
in AI throughout your
business functions.
For more information, we
recommend watching the session
on Responsible AI--
From Theory to
Practice by Tracy Frey.
In the transformational
phase, your data governance
is streamlined using automated
workflows to radically validate
new use cases against the
domain regulations and your AI
principles.
In addition, you
invest in AI safety
and robustness to
improve the reliability
and generalizability of your
machine-learning models.
The scale theme covers
using cloud-native services
and accelerators to scale your
machine-learning workflows.
In the tactical phase,
your organization
aimed at controlling the
cost of experimenting
with machine learning.
Thus, you usually
dedicate cloud resources
with limited compute power for
a few data scientists who work
with small, offline data sets.
At the strategic phase, data
ingest and transformation
are performed using
managed processing services
like Dataflow and Dataproc.
They execute large-scale
batch and streaming ETL jobs.
Similarly,
machine-learning training
and batched scoring
jobs are performed
using cloud-managed services.
This enable running powerful
machine-learning algorithms
on large data sets at scale
with no infrastructure overhead.
For example, we work with
a digital-native customer
who used to run their
machine-learning workflows
on dedicated VMs.
However, by moving to the AI
platform which provides managed
services to train and deploy
machine-learning models,
the customer now is able
to scale their training
and scoring jobs to more
markets as well as to reduce
the cost of running these jobs.
As you moves to the
transformational phase,
you invest in establishing
a unified and integrated
machine-learning
platform which helps
to streamline the transition
from experimentation
to production and to
serve all data scientists
and machine-learning
engineers and different teams.
This integrated
platform provides access
to standardized tools,
frameworks, templates,
services, accelerators,
and processes
for the entire organization.
Finally, we cover
the ultimate theme,
which concerns with
deploying, executing,
and operating machine-learning
workloads in production.
In the technical phase, the
process to build AI systems
is usually manual every
step, from data analysis
to preparation to model
training and deployment.
Such a manual process
prevents the organization
from scaling the number
of models they use
and the frequency of
updating these models.
As your organization moves
to the strategic phase,
you automate data processing
and analytics pipelines
to be executed on
recurrent schedules
or to tackle critical
events and triggers.
At this stage, you deploy
end-to-end continuous training
pipelines to regularly update
your machine-learning models
with the new data.
This enables your
model to rapidly adapt
to the changes in the
dynamics of your business.
For example, we're currently
working with a telecom company
to automate retraining their
propensity models using
TFX and Kubeflow pipelines,
allowing the models to be
updated weekly instead
of updating them manually
each six or eight weeks.
In the transformational
phase, your goal
is to develop a machine-learning
engineering culture
and practice that unifies
both machine-learning system
development and machine-learning
system operations.
We call that MLOps.
MLOps strongly advocates
automation and monitoring
at all steps of machine-learning
system construction.
With this approach,
you are looking
towards a shorter deployment
cycles, increased deployment
velocity, and faster
time to market.
This, however, requires
robust quality control
throughout the machine-learning
training and deployment phases
as well as continuous training
and continuous monitoring
of your model's
performance in production.
Back to Donna to conclude.
DONNA SCHUT: Thank you, Khalid.
To summarize, the three key
points of our framework are,
one, anyone can
use this framework.
No matter where
you're starting, you
can use this framework
to define your strategy
and drive successful adoption.
Two, success requires
an integrated lens.
In order to build an
effective AI capability,
you need to address six themes--
learn, lead, access,
secure, scale, and automate.
And three, there is value
every step of the way.
It's not about becoming
transformational
in every aspect.
It's about gaining
value in each phase.
So what can you do next?
You can create a
group of leaders
who will be responsible
for your AI strategy.
And from there,
each of you should
use this framework
to identify where
you are in your AI journey.
Then collectively set your goal.
Where do you envision
your organization going?
Based on the gaps,
establish a plan
for evolving your AI capability.
We are here to help you
every step of the way.
Check out our resources
and read our white paper
for more information.
Thank you for
watching this session.